ich weiß nicht was soll es bedeuten dass
ich so traurig bin ich stehe hier allein
vom plenarsaal und wer doch viel lieber
drinnen drin hatte schon mehrfach die
spritze gefüllt mit dem corona vakzin
heute wird hier gestritten ob das alle
bekommen für mich als poet ein
pflichttermin
wie stehen sie zum thema impfpflicht ich
bin total nebenpflicht sie sind für die
er nicht ganz da hin sagt fertig alle
alles gut und weiter geht das leben ja
es wird das zeug auch trinken wenn es
helfen würde wolfgang kubicki ist ja
gegen eine impfpflicht ist das
vielleicht das stärkste argument dafür
nein das stärkste argument ist dass wir
uns den panini virus müssen und dafür
ist sie endlich gut wolfgang kubicki
dagegen das amt eines parlaments poeten
ist das vielleicht stärkste argument
dafür nein texte argument dafür ist ja
dass wir gut mit sprache umgehen und
gerade in diesen zeiten was wieder
bostick ist was anderes eine andere
sprache haben seit wann tragen eine
brille jetzt nur für den bau einer mine
poetische aus ich sehe ich bei land den
lauterbach die glotze die stets lauter
machen bei friedrich merz stelle ich
gleich leise denn der verzapft ja eh nur
will ich nicht sagen stimme aber zu ein
hoch auf die dreifach impfung eine dose
ist eine dose ist eine dose
ich habe von von der ärztin die
wissenschaftlerin die gesagt hat du
lässt sich nicht impfen das ist wie das
tor ist leer und der elfmeter wird
geschossen der torwart ist nach hause
was glauben sie ließen sich dann in
thüringen eher durchsetzen impfpflicht
oder vegane thüringer rostbratwurst in
thüringen die vegane bratwurst es
realistischer als jetzt einfacher fehler
die die politiker machen ja ist dass man
diese impfpflicht nicht so ein bisschen
mit metaphern den leuten näher bringen
müssen sie verstehen die korona impfung
ist der erdbeermund der mit dem
damoklesschwert den heuhaufen der viren
zerteilt damit wir die nadel der
freiheit wieder finden das ist ja sowas
von eckig deutsch
ja dann haben sie mich schreibt meine
gedichte als endlich
so wie er manchmal anderen länder so die
franzosen oder so meinen wie die
deutsche sprache ist so sagen oh
là là führe so sehen sie können kein
französisch oder ich mache aber jetzt
nicht was ich jetzt eigentlich machen
wollte das reiße ich mich als zusammen
ich wollte dem virus mal meinen
mittelfinger zeigen das machen wir jetzt
im handel ich würde doch das machen wir
das kann ich schon wieder wir machen es
hinter dem blatt
jetzt bin ich drin im zentrum der macht
und fällt hierfür staatsknete rein doch
bis dieser posten und bargeld mehr lacht
muss ich wohl noch mächtig viel schleim
darum sage ich jetzt ganz frei heraus
sie sehen heute fantastisch aus leute
die kleinen gibt es schon genug in der
fertig und wir brauchen ja menschen die
widersprechen darum sage ich sollte ganz
frei heraus gesehen heute nicht so gut
besser aber reichte nicht
samstagabend eines impfverweigerer
atemlos durch die nacht hätte ich bloß
die impfung mitgemacht atemlos einfach
raus nur ich bleibe hier im krankenhaus
[Musik]
hallo leute ich bin der heute-show
hersteller wenn ihr mehr heißen scheiß
und liebst -
wollt dann abonniert jetzt den kanal
was zur hölle ist minimal hersteller